all right time for the hand of the hot
seat if you watch Joe Biden's
re-election announcement video you may
have seen something very interesting at
the end take a look at your screen and
see what it says on the bottom paid for
by the Democratic National Committee so
the DNC is all in for Biden and they've
rigged the primary before it even starts
remember they're going to bypass New
Hampshire go straight to South Carolina
they're not even holding any debates
despite the fact that a majority of
Democrats do not want Joe to run for a
second term but Joe isn't the only one
running Robert F Kennedy Jr recently
entered the race by the way and he's up
to 19 percent in the polls that's a
pretty big number I think and author
Marianne Williamson she ran back in 2020
if you recall she is back in the race
and she announced her campaign before
Biden did and she did it longer than
three minutes and didn't have to tape it
uh and she's asking Joe Biden to debate
her and she joins us now from Washington
DC tonight the swamp
Marianne how are you
thank you thank you I actually am going
to start out in agreement with you I
think we'll disagree on other stuff
um I think it would be fair for Joe
Biden to debate you and Robert F Kennedy
Jr why do you think he's not debating
and do you believe he's in a steep
cognitive decline
well I think in a democracy what's
important is that people have a right to
see their options I think this is an
extremely important time in American
history and anyone who feels moved to
run for President should have their say
and the voters should hear what they
have to say they should hear their
agenda and the voters should decide who
they want to be president or two of my
question do you believe he's in a major
cognitive decline I I'm not a doctor I'm
not somebody who is testing his brain I
think every American citizen has to when
you look at the president and listen to
the president does he seem like somebody
that has the strength and stamina and is
articulate to be president
running if I didn't think that I was a
better candidate I think I have the
energy and certainly I have the idea you
got to answer my question because I
don't I'm just I'm not going to come on
Fox News and talk to you Sean and say
something like that I'm not going to I
think every American can decide but if
you believe it you would tell us would
you
I don't I I my mind doesn't go into that
I don't believe that the energy is being
demonstrated that I believe will be
necessary in order to take on either
DeSantis or Trump in 2024.
all right you said that we need an
economic U-turn in this country what
system economically do you support I'm a
capitalist I believe in limited
government more freedom lower taxes uh
and energy Independence what do you want
you know I think our our capitalist
system has lost some of its Soul over
the last 50 years I believe that
capitalism you know uh Adam Smith who is
the main architect of free market
capitalism said that free market
capitalism cannot exist outside an
ethical context I think public policy
has to have ethics so I believe that the
American people our safety our health
and our well-being should come before
short-term profits for huge corporate
entities I believe that there are other
states
I want to dig down deep here what do you
think I want for example lower taxes
more freedom less government uh
bureaucracy and I want energy
Independence I want border secure okay I
want Law and Order
okay so let's go with each one the first
one take take each one at a time the
first one you said was lower taxes I
want lower taxes for middle class people
I want higher taxes at four people who
have huge amounts of wealth and are
living at the effect of public policies
how high I want to see a wealth tax I
think people I think people who first of
all I think we should look in 2017 we
have a two two trillion dollar tax cut
83 cents of every dollar went to the
very richest Americans and the very
smart you are in the economy middle
class what percentage of income taxes
did the bottom 50 of Americans pay what
percent it's not about the I'm not going
to talk to you about the bottom middle
class the bottom half I'm going to talk
to you about the upper class the one
percent so you asked me what I want to
see I want to see 50 million or more I
think people should pay an extra two
percent in taxes wouldn't affect their
day and if someone has a billion dollars
they should okay you want to each
American based on their need from each
American according uh to their ability
you know talk about cliches
is that a statement that you agree with
I'm asking
well as a you know as a concept but once
again that we should talk about what's
wrong that's Karl Marx's words not mine
well thank God I didn't say yes because
then you'd be calling me a marker you
kind of did
[Applause]
would you support me in this do you
support energy Independence and we ought
not be importing oil from countries that
hate us and countries like Venezuela
would you support me on that I think
that you I would support you that we
should not be getting oil or selling
Arms by the way to countries that hate
us but I also want to see a habitable
planet in a hundred years I want to see
massive investments in green energy I
want to see a just transition from a
dirty economy to a clean economy we're
now spending over 50 billion dollars
every government agency is spending
something on on the climate alarmist
religious cult how much how many
billions of dollars do you want to
invest in it give me a number
listen we have 858 billion dollars right
now in our military expenditure every
year and they are the largest
institutional emitter of greenhouse
gases and the Congressional budget
office hardly a liberal organization
says that we could take out a trillion
of that over the next decade and cut
greenhouse gases natural gas is a clean
Burning uh fossil fuel all right I got
to ask you about some of the weird stuff
you've said okay
okay you you have said your body is
merely your space station
from Once you beam your love to the
universe don't just relate to the
station relate to the beams you said
everyone feels on some level like an
alien in this world because we are we
come from another Realm Of Consciousness
and uh long from home what the hell does
that mean
I'm surprised to hear you say that
because I I would think that you would
recognize that as a very traditional
religious and spiritual perspective that
we are spirits that God created us as
spirits and that is what we are and we
are here to love one another and we
don't feel deeply at home on a spiritual
level on this planet because this world
is not based on love the way it should
be I I think those words all right
that's a fair answer I'm a Christian I
believe in God the father that God
created every man woman and child on
this Earth I believe in Jesus Christ the
son that died and resurrect uh came back
from the dead to save all of us from our
sins that's what I believe
so anyway Marianne I appreciate you
taking the heat thanks for being here
you're welcome back anytime hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else